l'une juché sur les épaules de l'autre
il brosse il frotte il astique ils sont
en tout dix adolescents
répartis en deux groupes à nettoyer les
panneaux de signalisation des neuf
communes historique qui forment clos à
les trois rivières en contrepartie de
ces travaux la ville leur financera
l'examen du code de la route
première étape du permis de conduire ici
pour se dépasser c'est pas forcément
facile là bas beaucoup de moyens de
transport qui combat d'avoir le permis
je trouve ça génial surtout qu'ils nous
aident une aide financière de 360 euros
pour chacun des dix ados comme kilian 17
ans je suis issu d'une famille de cinq
ans et cinq enfants
donc ce qui fait que j'ai on a on peut
pas se permettre de prouver faire
attention à l'argent
les dix premiers inscrits et plus
motivés ont été retenus pour cette
première opération mise en place à
destination des jeunes de 15 à 17 ans
sans condition de ressources
ça nous permet de montrer aux jeunes
qu'on est prêt à financer des choses à
faire des choses pour eux mais qu'en
échange de de ces droits là bas ils ont
aussi des devoirs et ça ils le
comprennent sur une fois les cinq jours
de travaux terminés
la ville leur mais ce diplôme n'est pas
l'argent donc ils en sont directement
l'hôtel cole ne donnant pas du tout
l'argent aux jeunes c'est pour être sûr
que ce soit et utilisés à bon escient
en attendant les jeunes en ont profité
pour réviser entre eux et dans la bonne
humeur les panneaux de signalisation en
cinq jours ils en ont nettoyé entre 4 et